speaking of I have a lot of Star Trek to
talk about but you you have a fantastic
resume if someone has actually never
seen anything that you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why and um oh maybe
that and why but because because that
was uh such a well-rounded role you know
it wasn't just comedy or just it was it
was just so well very well-rounded
character were you a obviously it's a
little generic but like were you a fan
of Star Trek before the role or how much
were you like oh I need to watch a lot
of Star Trek all of a sudden oh okay I
had not really seen it and I told that
to the producers when they called and
when they called I thought they must
have the wrong number because I thought
of all of all people to be unstarted I
didn't you know ever imagine such a
thing but it was so much fun but I I
really was not in the Star Trek world
and to tell you the truth I didn't watch
a lot of it because I just kind of
wanted to stay where we were in strange
new worlds I just wanted to be president
and not compare it to other
things and sure what what can you I've
seen the first six episodes I don't want
to spoil anything
um of season two but what are you
allowed to say about your character well
I just I mean I could say who I am that
I uh I have taken over being the
engineer on the ship from him or who was
my student uh uh years ago and I guess I
could say that I've been alive for
centuries
so I have quite a background and I know
a lot about everyone there and I know my
job and I'm I think I'm very opinionated
because I I have been around much longer
than anyone else and I think I claim
that territory I get pretty
straightforward and opinionated I that's
very uh yes I agree with everything you
just said that's so pretty so you saw
episode six I have I'm I I've seen the
first six but uh I'm trying to be
spoiler free
um
yeah I'm trying to be good
um I don't want to hold the interview
for you know uh eight weeks from now
um so I I am curious what what did you
think it was going to be like making
Star Trek and being on the set of
strange new worlds versus how it
actually was I think
um
you know I thought that well it presents
itself when you read it at first as a
lot of very difficult technical language
you know involved right but so I think
the surprise for me was sort of
um the emotional layer that is there
which is a very uh there's kind of a
profound emotional level for a lot of
the characters and and that that
surprised to me I didn't expect that
season two is ten episodes uh do you
have a favorite of the ten episodes no
because I haven't watched them because
until they come come out and watch one
at a time like everybody else that's
probably smarter than what I did I
watched all six back to back basically
and it was very you have a payment
uh I I can't say it because uh it would
spoil things okay you're so good yeah
listen I've been doing this a long time
say it again you're so careful that's
very nice I'm trying to be good but you
know um uh listen I already have to rap
with you I'm already getting the signal
um I'm just gonna say I'm again I've
been a fan of yours for a long time it's
really cool to get to talk with you if I
had more time I would have brought up
Princess Bride oh thanks so much I
appreciate that Steve